The Mandelbrot set is one of the most iconic images in all of math.
You start with some complex number, c, and then you recursively define
a sequence of complex numbers where the sequence starts with 0,
and each new value is defined to be the square of the previous value, plus c.
So, for example, on the very first iteration, you take 0 squared plus c,
meaning z1 is just c, and then for the next iteration,
you take that number squared plus c, meaning z2 is c squared plus c,
and so on and so forth.
Each new value is the square of the previous plus c.
Depending on the choice for that value c, sometimes the sequence stays bounded,
and sometimes it blows up to infinity.
If you color all of the values of c that cause this process to stay bounded black,
and you apply some gradient of colors to the other values,
where the color depends on how quickly the process blows up to infinity,
you get this iconic, cardioid-with-bubbles shape.